[Music]  six years ago  I started this YouTube channel with only  one goal to share my passion for voice  acting with someone who might care  thanks to the SCP foundation on the  community surrounding it I was able to  build a YouTube channel based around  that exact thing and today I reached  100,000 subscribers something at the  beginning I never thought would actually  happen I'll have a proper 100,000  celebration video later on I just want  to make a grant so if you'll only need  to wait a little while longer hopefully  there's nothing else I want to say  except thank you this channel has  changed my life sorry about the cheesy  ending  thank you very much for listening if  indeed you still are and you're all  dismissed goodbye  it's quatre Nikita